it's been a long time coming yeah I've
reached out to Andrew Santino
um I don't know how many times too many
um and uh every time I asked can you do
my podcast I'll bring it to you it'll be
so easy
um it was uh
man I got too much going on uh like and
it got to a point where I was so
frustrated that I lashed out in the most
humiliating way it was very funny yeah
you should put the tech stuff on the we
should make t-shirts of what he said to
you [__] you bro and I legitimately was
like is this for real immediately is a
comic you're like there's a bit he's
doing a bit and I was about to go [__]
you bro I'm like no no he's mad I could
I was like no he's actually frustrated
my favorite part about that whole thing
is he said eat [__] eat [__]
fast I misspelled eat [__] your anger
restricts you from actually getting the
the diss out
[__] and then you said yeah I'm gonna go
eat [__] yeah
I can feel my face getting red
um but here's the thing I've never heard
Steve talk like that in my life that's
why when he was like dude and I was like
bro let's let's get out of here let's go
somewhere it
as is often the case it had nothing to
do with with you no no I knew that like
I was uh I've been a comic for 20 years
like I get it by now yeah when when you
when I fight with Bobby when when I get
into it with any friends in our world I
know right away what's really going on
it's some other [__] you're fried it's a
relationship you're tired it's family
[__] it's dude it's always everything
else I bur and I Burr one time
Burr one time and I had a little thing
and it wasn't a big deal but
I was bummed I was like really hurt
because I look up to him I respect him
like he's a hero oh yeah and then he
something happened it's no money's
business but it was like it bummed me
out
and then a couple days later he texted
me because he's like the greatest dude
on Earth and was like I'm sorry man I
didn't I don't know why I said that I
don't know why this went this way but he
was like
straight up it's you know it's because
of XYZ and explained to me like what was
going on I was like oh good I got it I
didn't take it as
me I knew some other [__] was up and he
was like that had nothing to do with you
yeah but for some reason you were
[__] in the line of fire and you got
clipped and I was like it happened it's
I let that stuff go so fast dude it goes
away it's like my dad I grew up in a
world of lies and Chaos of my dad was a
drug addict and not a prison who never
showed up but said he was going to show
up so I always know about the other side
of it where you're like something else
is going on yeah definitely I had but
you showed up to him for to for today
for me dad you were here
fortunately I I uh I came around pretty
quickly and and no you did it was good I
acknowledged where I had come up short
yeah but did your dad ever tell you to
eat [__]
he would finish it he'd say eat [__] I
uh I was typing so fast and and I wrote
eat
s-h-i-y I misspelled it and just it was
already sent each shy is kind of a cool
and then he sent it again yeah oh I
misspelled to eat [__] twice yeah yeah
you should make each guy shirts I wanted
to make a text bubble that said eat shy
and do like like something
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude